Rick wiles is a Christian based conspiracy
theorist and a racist and an all around horrible
person for the things that he has said and
done over the last several decades. We've
talked about him before, but not in a while,
and he now has a program on something called
True News, Tru News, which he created. He
used to work for the Christian Broadcasting
Network. He eventually went over Trinity Broadcasting
Network. These are all extremists far right?
Christian media organizations, and as you
can probably guess, just from what I've told
you so far, Rick wiles is anti-gay. Rick wiles
is anti-immigrant. Rick wiles is antisemitic.
He's checking off all of the normal boxes
that we would expect them to check, but he's
now going after fo meat burgers, I guess.
Veggie Burgers, Black Bean Burgers, mushroom
Burger's lab, grown meat, impossible burger's.
That's a new, a Vegan Burger that is around,
which I've tried before. I guess all of these
are part of the problem that is designed to
steal people's souls by preventing them from
being able to be born again. Take a look at
how he said it. Don't take my word for it.
When you go to your favorite fast food restaurant,
you're going to be eating a fake hamburger.
You're going to go to the grocery store and
buy a pound of fake hamburger or a fake steak
and you won't know that it was grown in some
big corporations laboratory. This is the nightmare
world that they're taking us into their God's
creation. Why they want to change human DNA
so that you can be born again.
Hmm.
That's where they're going with this to change
the DNA of humans. So it will be impossible
for a human to be born again. They there.
They want to create a race of soulless creatures
on this planet.
I know I've said this before, but if fake
burgers are so terrible and if his god is
so powerful, why didn't his God just prevent
the creation of Vegan Burgers, right? Like
if this is such an evil that needs to be rooted
out, why would his all powerful and all knowing
God allow the creation of Vegan burgers and
this entire critique about Vegan burgers destroying
people's souls and all of it. This is the
wrong critique of Vegan burgers. The right
critique of some of these burgers is that
they're mostly not very good. I've had some
pretty good non meat burgers like at some
restaurants that make them in house, but every
prepackaged Veggie Burger I've tried has been
mediocre. Even that impossible burger that
people are up in arms about it saying it's
so great, recently tried it, it looks like,
and has the consistency of raw meat even after
you've grilled it.
It's just not that good. That's the tragedy,
not that it's going to destroy your soul as
I as a massive plot to prevent you from becoming
born again. And by the way, if you're district,
if you want to destroy people's souls that
prevent them from becoming born again, Christians
through getting them to eat Veggie Burgers,
you're failing. Because most people I know
don't like Veggie burgers. The veggie burgers
are going to have to get way better if you
want more than a tiny fraction of the population
to start regularly eating them in order to
self destroy their own souls. But seriously,
does this guy believe what he's saying or
is it all stick maybe to sell stuff or I don't
even know if he sells stuff. Maybe just to
make money and get donations. I went to the
true news website. It's completely whacked
out with conspiracy theories, but you can
donate, they will accept shares of stock.
You can donate cryptocurrency, you can leave
money to them in your will. Can you imagine?
They will also accept precious metals from
you. It's, it's really a scene that they're
going there. And then, by the way, and this
is where it all comes full circle, where you
can take action. Uh, you can submit prayer
requests no matter how big or small the requests
they say, you can submit prayer requests on
their website. Please go to true news.com/prayer.
That's t r u news.com/prayer submit prayer
requests that are related to the David Pakman
show. They can be inside jokes. Anything goes.
If any of these get aired or answered by Rick
Whiles, we will absolutely play them on the
show. If we hear about it, which you might
have to tell us since I certainly don't watch
this garbage, but true.com/prayer. Let's see
if we can get some, uh, progressive or David
Pakman show inside jokes mentioned there.